now the other domain that last oh man I
want to talk about where we have simply
no precedent out there is in some ways
even more abstract in this world of
metaphor and it could be summarized here
in this way which is this human ability
in some settings to gain the strength
and the will to do something from the
irrefutable evidence that that something
cannot be what do I mean by that let me
make this a little bit less abstract and
instead a quote from Kierkegaard and if
you subscribe to this particular type of
belief system this notion that what
religiosity is often about is the
ability to hold two contradictory facts
in your head at the same time or two
contradictory beliefs let me make it a
little bit less abstract than that this
is a nun named sister Helen Prejean and
lots of people probably saw the movie
back when dead man walking which was
about her this is a nun who has spent
her time ministering to the needs of men
einem on death row in a maximum-security
prison somewhere down in the south and
inevitably she is asked by all sorts of
people when hearing she has spent her
life solace saying these terrifying evil
creatures who are as damaging as any
humans can be saying how can you do this
how can you have just spent your whole
life doing this and she always has the
same answer the less forgivable the fact
the less forgivable what the person has
done the more we must find the means to
forgive them the less lovable the person
is the more we must find the means to
love them and as a strident atheist this
strikes me as one of the most irrational
nutty magnificent things we are capable
of as a species the more something
cannot be the more we have to make sure
it is and to finish up here in lots of
ways that is the realm where we can do
our most uniquely human things built out
of a danger of a certain human wisdom
you sit there and you look at enough
about what's going on in the world and
you learn enough about it and you become
wise about it and there is almost an
inevitable conclusion that you have to
reach which is none of us can make
things better
because we're too small and they're too
big and they're too powerful and it's
not going to matter anyway and none of
us can make things change and what we
have to deal with is the notion that the
more clearly irrefutable and arguably
it's the case that you cannot make a
difference the more that must be the
motivation to make a difference and have
that as a moral imperative so at the end
of the day we do smelly stuff just like
hamsters and we do strange things with
our stress hormones but at the end of
the day this realm of being able to take
abstractions and turn metaphors into
things as powerful is the most visceral
of sensory effects and to do all of this
in the context of moral imperatives we
are an entirely different planet from
other species